i don't know if you
know there's a book by hemingway called
old man in the sea
and i've heard of it and uh ernest
hemingway ernest hemingway yeah
and he uh there's a there's an old man
that basically uh
catches an 18-footer but it can't pull
it in doesn't have the strength so they
together spend
while the sharks eat away at it i mean
there's this very powerful
story i think one in the nobel prize but
he says
it's better to be lucky the old man says
better be lucky
but i would rather be exact that that
that way when luck comes you're ready so
let me ask
uh what do you think about luck
do you believe in free will that we have
actions
that control the direction destination
of our life or does
luck and some other outside forces
really land you where you end up
for me i'm not about luck but i do think
there is luck is involved
but i think it's mostly created uh
just how lucky you are through
preparations
and things happen things have happened
in my life
forever and a lot of good things
and a lot of people could say hey you've
been pretty lucky to win all these
awards
i don't know if you analyze my life
i don't think it was involved with luck
you know i think it was more involved
with preparation
and you know and again science had you
been smarter
had you understood that you could do
some things
and be just as lucky that'd be great but
i'm only as smart
as today so when i was training in my
life and me even training people
in my life as of that moment that's how
lucky i am
to uh be able to um have whatever is
available to me
and that's what you call that a lot of
science so for me i
i think that uh you know like right now
if i look back
yeah i do a lot of things different uh
just because
things are proven differently like i'd
give people water during practice and i
did
and i would let them change their
running wrestling shoes into running
shoes to run sprints on the concrete
or i would actually maybe um maybe i had
a guy climb
12 ropes after practice one after
another
and then maybe the next day i'd do it
again ah you know
i might not make him do it the next day
i might let him recover
a little bit more and uh
you got to learn keep adding to your
philosophy
and your philosophy may have been great
at that time but it's at that time
and what is really important is where
you at
with this time today and so there's
better
ways to do things now if you ever take
attitude out of it
and just depend on total science
then you know you're not going to be as
as uh you know i think as i i listened
to a couple of
people that are really pretty famous
people uh
one of them was john irving he was a
writer yeah
and he told me he said you think i
really
learned how to be a great writer in uh
writing school i
he said yeah i learned a lot there but
really what gave me the ability to stay
focused just to work extra hours to be
more disciplined
was wrestling practices that's right he
was a wrestler yeah yeah he goes i go
back to that
that's what gave me that chance you know
and and there's a guy in iowa that uh
a guy named norman borlaug he uh
he he learned he he invented a process
to feed
the underprivileged countries of the
world
and he was a wrestler and he said the
same thing and he
he worked extremely hard and he said uh
i give a lot of credit to the sport of
wrestling uh
and even though i was i'm known for this
and i got a statue in
in washington dc because i saved a
billion lives
plus uh i'm gonna give wrestling a lot
of credit
so you know i think some of these
mma stars and some of these guys
that maybe weren't wrestlers that had to
wrestle russell
had to fight wrestling guys and stuff
missed a little bit there
but i think the ones that did have
wrestling probably have a really good
chance and can adapt to the other ones
but you know i think every martial art
or every activity is good and you
probably can't skip any but i don't
think they're ever going to
overlook and say that wrestling's
pretty not are not valuable because
it is however that doesn't mean you're
going to make it you still got to take
the values and apply it
whatever area you're going to be in and
and some people forget that
some people can't get over
the highness of getting your arm raised
in a wrestling match
and i and you know what what's even
greater than
me getting my arm raised is that i if
i'm a coach or if i doesn't belong with
you
that you get your arm raised yeah and
even if you don't get your arm raised
it's what you walk away with
and how and how you learn to uh
handle that as well because there's
going to be some losses but you don't
want many
because you don't want to get used to
losing i can tell you that it's the
hunger for the wind
it's the brotherhood the sisterhood of
the wrestling room
and it's hard work and science that's
going to be luck
at the end of the day absolutely that
luck you know
i'm you know i i like luck but i think
it's created by uh
the opportunity there that you make your
luck you make your luck yeah
dan it was a huge honor thank you for
welcoming me into your home and for
having this conversation
yeah no problem good man
you